o una cosa per termini qua bisogni lanci
ma tu sei uno di quelli che rimorchia
sul web
e tu pensi di parlare come gioca in
realtà palli con uno tutti i 146 ad
herat i ragazzi su fornite da un po che
non facevo video solo con pietro alon
fine di entrare in wonder world tour che
pratica abbiamo visto che una specie di
puzzle parkour e noi ce li intendiamo
amico mio non ho mai giocato un puzzle
procura effettivamente credo che sia
dobbiamo risolvere gli enigmi nel mentre
che facciamo parte
non era semplice fare posto ad ora
ritroviamo anche liquido testiamo la
nostra intelligenza entrava sotto per
favore regini informazioni non leggere
niente né avanti ma cosa vuol dire di
sette colli aprì la porta
ok si comincia ragazzi questo è il
parkour puzzle puzzle parkour non solo
lo chiamerò il video ma chi se ne frega
allora la prima cosa da fare credo sia
che fare climbing su noi riuscito a fare
la cosa giusta subito incredibile ma sei
pazzo
grande è l'unico punto in questo grande
amica mi sta roba per una volta ragazzi
pietro ha fatto una roba decente bravo
bravo a vico c'era il fuoco a picco nei
mercati visto che si parte dall'inizio e
abbiamo un hp cerchiamo di non premere
intestino ok va bene l'ex gallo ragazzi
non facciamo male non ci facciamo del
male a vicenda perché
profumo di vita allora tra l'altro
eletto nella descrizione che questo è un
pianeta alieno e noi dobbiamo
semplicemente un pianeta alieno
sicuramente non è terrestre siamo tra
prati nella loro base dobbiamo scappare
invece un certo punto c'è un check point
dove l'acqua ovvia perfetto quindi
voleri allora direi di andare al piano
di sopra in questo momento bravo mentre
fai le croci let's go non so non so dove
stiamo andando per hai capito che siamo
sul piano italiano è mai capito che
forse è più difficile
non ci credo se vincerà ma non ci credo
dai come fatto allora devi saltare
arrivare sopra e poi non è che ce l'ho
fatta sono fatta sotto attenzione e poi
basta che vai proprio noi proprio grazie
fortissimo ti puoi togliere grazie e poi
da che parte andare
e poi vai tu vai ti sfida terminò
aspetta che avevo paura di morire
tu sai che so che mi mandi davanti a una
trappola qualcosa di non salire qua
sopra
ok è poi rimbalzato ok tanto fanno
rumore
ti puoi togliere da davanti ma è
cortesia mi hai fatto prima ha avuto
paura ci fosse un [ __ ] io ti giuro
che piuttosto facciamo passava col mio
cane riprendere avanti dove deve
trovarci un check point stop o no
l'ultimo dei classici che poi ma dove
l'avrebbe dovuto invece sono io e se ci
arrivi allora poi c'è una torta parlo io
e maria bello ma che bello è bellissimo
ok se maggiorenne con le ho letto che
bisogna prenderne tipo 15 per finire il
gioco
siamo due deficienti allo ragazzi e
bellissimo questo questo specie di largo
dove devi fare un micro parkour però la
parte puzzle di questo gioco quale
dovrebbe essere perché forse è meglio se
ci concentriamo sul barbour
chissenefrega del puzzle mi sono
dimenticato ragazzi che ho attivato
l'autorun quindi non c'è bisogno di
schiacciare lo shift percorrere il
problema è che sono stupido papà hai
fatta
non può non far capire loro che sono
morti però potresti rimettere in editing
queste due frasi che mi sono piaciute
magari anche un paradenti per farlo
sembrare un po più scemo grazie proprio
lui mamma mia che pro perfetto ragazzi
parkour è sempre casa mia
il parkour è veramente sempre casa mia
in qualsiasi gioco non c'è verso una
statua mai che mi mette un asse
incredibile l'ho sempre detto
perfetto allora si può andare avanti
tanto sembrano dei denti volar neri che
volano gigante quindi seguiamo sto
tragitto perché non sei qua spiega mi è
solo credo comunque che poi l'altro è
vieni qua vieni qua perché mi sa che qua
c'è ancora un pezzo avanti bellissimo e
l'ho raggiunto non so se c'è un check
point vi prego fate di trovare c'è poi
ragazzi con roma non so secolo o tanto
c'è poi di qua dove sei avanti avanti
avanti avanti a the mouth di vero che
c'e una è partita una specie di voi
attenzione ma devi saltare vita a lo
devi saltare ti devi ricordare dove
passa esaltarlo giocato talmente tanta
che temario nella mia vita che per me è
una bazzecola sta cosa è per me un po
meno amico mio
devi imparare a conoscere port col
demonio allora fuori devi ricordarti il
tragitto che fanno esaltare al momento
giusto quindi senza guardare è molto
difficile ma secondo me ce la puoi fare
12 emo l'altro torna indietro
questo come sempre questa prova monetina
dove ma dolore al tronco tronco a
capirla io penso che cerca una strada
che ogni codice che l'attore che
utilizzate la mia intelligenza si
incrementava non c'è bisogno me lo dici
io sono un problema è amico mio
sono morto lo ci credo bene ciao vai
avanti per cortesia che è già un casino
allora dove dobbiamo andare c'è una
porta aperta entriamo nella porta
potrebbe essere un trabocchetto per
occhio
ok
no mi sa che mi sono cagato addosso e
guarda c'è un albero e poi salirà quindi
qua e poi qua sopra perfetto qua c'è un
buco di tipo di storia che perfetto
vieni corri
altro check point come correre io sto
rafforzati attivato automatica sai che
quando dovessero aver cambiato la vita è
una moneta amico mio sono cinque ce l'ha
se la fa un terzo della mappa però
diciamo sul pianeta alieno stanno
studiando le monete e le piante le pen
italiano dove sei nato tutto andiamo di
qua ma come si può andare 18 no questo è
uno di quelli dove ti devi droppare e
scendere pian piano santi spa no no
perché se un drop per solito al
contrario se penso a come si forma il
suo manga tipo dei ti fanno nera delle
ville come l'hai fatto la caga ta
pazzesca è una cagata pazzesca ma è il
draw per più semplice di questo pianella
che si è buttato fatto talmente tanti
draw per la mia vita che non ha idea che
non si capisce bene dove andare cosa che
ti sparava dov'è ma dove non si vede
vamos ma c'è una strada perché pirla
siamo da eva facciamo una strada
tranquillissima di guado dei peer
l'incredibile checkpoint allora poi
seguiamo i fiorellini porca l'oca celica
occhio soprattutto delle trappole e
niente devi farla tutta di fila
ricordati quando c'è la scala non devi
saltare perché sennò sbando ok sarebbero
subito dopo sono bravissimo no a praga e
bellissima star o bellino ti prego vieni
è bellissimo
ieri vi è uno slide fichissima vai prima
tu vai al taqwa e poi dopo no non salta
adesso o che ora che prima volta salta
ora dopo a fare all'indietro capito cosa
vuol dire niente la foto la prima volta
e basta noi dobbiamo farla sta cosa la
faccio una cosa che ti spara flash a
perfetto quando non salti qua salti poi
subito la passanti ancora in parte dal
indietro esatto dall alto rischio sai
cos'è quale problema mio che non riesco
a prendere la scala all'indietro so che
ce lo fa poi fatto ormai fatto danni
talvolta di casa che giorno è
difficilissimo
e veramente difficile spetta perché qua
e prendere sua scala che è difficile
almeno mi spara dritto mi spara storto
mammamia proprio lui ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi a posto adesso posso anche
morire il male bene possiamo andare alla
siamo a metà mappa più o meno rai rai è
veramente carina molto molto bella molto
carina si non so che quello che stai
pensando che le guardie rasta parte
mamma mia
i quali e bellissimi parkour a e qui
sotto ci hanno messo a forza ma faceva
schifo ci ha messo 250 ore x pharma
porco schifo devi saltare su un tronco e
l'altro che sta roba mi ricorda la
vulcano run tu l'hai mai fatta da volcan
oran e casinò che la magra fatto insieme
non l'abbiamo fatta con sasha camera
nella pratica nella vado iniziata la
questione di tronchi così tutto quelli
con il ghiaccio ma no anno la notte ma
dopo la prima la resina basata non
cincischi amadu saltar su questi qua mi
saranno ok no sbagliata c'è un gate c'è
un tronco che non ci puoi stare sopra
mai un bite adesso devo devo saltare il
culo ok e poi sull'altro subito dopo
perfetto amico perché qua non c'è cosa
metta che arrivò e ti dico come hai
fatto a saltare sono stati sul tronco
dritto benissimo benissimo tesoro è come
si fa qua allora quasi fa che cambi
gioco no aspetta
produttori est primo contest dell'acqua
perfetto 6 temerario l'hai provato da
solo avrei voluto hai sacrificato io per
una volta per la smetterà per forza dei
ragazzi non c'era nient'altro qua deve
saltare sicuro su questo
e invece no se fossi in mezzo e si così
viva uno zio africano non era l'uomo si
vuole la ora però mi sa che devi fare un
percorso sti fiori 4 come ci salviamo la
sopra cioè può intraprendere
ok sono trovato ho trovato devi fare
percorso i fiori
mio dio data c'è un cestino nascosto
dentro ogni fiore quindi vista
suggestiva capito molto carina questa
roba non volevano mettere nella
spazzatura da sola perché faceva un po
schifo però hanno messo i cd fiori per
abbellirla tutti intorno
ok non è un botto colorato della nostra
figlia è una tua bellissima ma è una
delle più belle che ho giocato finora a
livello di artisti soprattutto perché ti
fai un ti fa fuori in modo easy non si
può saltare passo brasa i viola si
poteva saperlo solo importanti salti
sempre un pelo più alto di volo gli
attivisti sembra ottenete primadonna non
ci sarà nessuna di moneta ma no che
pirla su un caduto l'ultimo salto equa
come faccio sua ok c'è nella del dente
qua i denti che erano certi gol perfetto
ok ce l'ho fatta ho fatto
c'è un check point e grazie a dio è
accaduto c'era chi mette del ghiaccio a
un certo punto è molto carino quindi
ragazzi se vi è piaciuto questo primo
episodio di parkour puzzle con pietro
lasciato un bel mi piace attivatela
campanellina vicino a sé iscriviti anche
per rimanere aggiornati sui video che
escono coltivavano il possibilità è
veramente figo è una delle più belle
forse anche la più bella che abbiamo
giocato parola di mappa credo perché
fatta veramente bene gli scritti del
canale come sempre ci viviamo
[Musica]